talking [ __ ] about Europe the guy at
Customs from Florence
we had to stop in Germany where the [ __ ]
did we go Frankfurt okay
the guy Customs there he like chirped at
me for what like he was like roasting me
it was crazy it's like 8 30 in the
morning okay I handed my passport I'm
like hey man is there food in this
terminal he's like gosh there's food
no McDonald's oh no way
and then he like looks at his co-worker
and they start chuckling
I mean he got you good dude dude I was
and you know now that I got the hardware
I'm like in front of my wife
you're gonna do this to me in front of
my wife
so then well I got news for you I'm
vegan yeah yeah
he starts laughing harder yeah
so
I laughed
yeah there's not even an American thing
anymore dude McDonald's is [ __ ]
everywhere I know but he was trying to
call me fat no he was calling you
American probably no it's that but he's
calling me everything okay American
gluttonous all that okay you know he was
like this close to being like uh there
there's no Vats of uh you know whatever
the [ __ ] that you can jump into
you know clearly I'm still starched from
The Experience because I can't even come
with a joke right now seriously well so
he says that and I kind of chuckle and I
go
oh yeah if it's back there I don't want
it man and he goes
and he kind of like says some other [ __ ]
and he's like there's a he's like
there's a smoking patio I'm like oh I'm
not European nah then he coughed he goes
one month in Germany
to prison yeah
coveted lockdown that was another thing
it was raining in Frankfurt so I think
it was
everyone was just had something as he
stamping my passport he's Hawking some
[ __ ] up he's like
there's a bakery
smearing his hands all over my [ __ ] I
looked at his co-worker for a second I
could tell his co-worker in that glass
box was kind of feeling you know I want
to be out of here definitely getting
sick from this dude I went to go get
some food lady serving my food
haha my damn everybody's gate attendance
everybody so whatever
I'm saying all this to lead up
I've never seen someone use the word by
as it's intended
or maybe this wouldn't be as intended as
much as this guy saw at the gate to come
home this [ __ ] he was loud he
hated everyone he was just screaming at
everybody please don't stand here please
to this they're not any bit of
instruction he could work for the
airline yeah yeah I'm sorry he worked
for the airline um he had a weak spot
though for dogs okay if you're a single
woman with a dog that boy was dude this
girl walks up she's like um I was just
wondering if I can he just looks at the
dog he's like you want a pre-board
absolutely go right this way there's a
there's another lady in like a track
suit with a Gucci roller and her little
dog
straight up to her did you want
pre-boarding
I'm like this fool I never I feel like I
was like you had Ollie with you didn't
you he didn't give a [ __ ] okay I'm a
dude yeah right I'm with my lady he
didn't care yeah I felt like I was at
the club yeah you see a girl the dog he
just like lift up the gate he's like
free
so whatever this dude he would bark at
people
[Music]
because we had to do a pre-screening to
come home
every person he'd scream at or talk to
at the end of the conversation he'd be
like you need to go over there they're
gonna check you in and you come back
here okay bye
really every person damn
okay thanks bye next
it's like well he said bye yeah yeah we
gotta walk away
that's so good yeah that is really good
bye bye
he didn't even do the yeah bye
so yeah lean and I just sat there like
crying laughing just watching him it's
like every minute do you have a question
Miss okay stay over here please thank
you what
oh okay
the last thing I gotta say you know
every time I travel I gotta complain
about a [ __ ] toilet yeah
Frankfurt toilet
the flush is busted the water is just
like it's like a permanent bidet okay
okay I wrote this down because it was
like the toilet seat was so small it
legitimately felt like [ __ ] through
a basketball hoop into a creek wait what
like I was like sitting over this like
small hole okay and then I just the
whole time just
hitting the back of my ass what yeah
it's just bideting me as I'm trying to
[ __ ]
wait the water was like erupting into
your ass the toilet water because the
toilet okay so the toilet was so small
there was like this like and and the way
the water came in fed through it was
like a it was like a small waterfall and
that was like broken it was snow the
toilet was so small that it was like
shooting back up from the base so it's
just ew yeah and it's hitting your ass
yes
you definitely have like some skin
disease or something now from that on
your [ __ ] I mean I just I like you
know one of these yeah you know I'm like
I I just went through like three
churches I should be fine I just like
lifted my dick and balls up and I just
like cross my fingers
you know
[Laughter]
yeah it was it was the craziest Deuce
I've taken in a minute damn yeah
yeah you're a bad Wi-Fi small toilets I
don't know how they're you like Europe
yo let's go yeah you like Andis I almost
did get you yeah yeah that's a reverse
one though because it would be like
you're up in my mouth yeah
oh you wait yeah I guess I am yeah oh
did I just get myself
come here
ew come here
um
damn it oh yeah I don't know how their
hips aren't [ __ ] up from those roads
oh yeah it's like bro I don't ever want
to hear an Uber driver complain
being a taxi driver in Italy
get the [ __ ] out any one of those guys
you could throw him in a suit he could
raise some formula one yeah
because like the is it just like
cobblestones and it's Cobblestone yes
narrow and all their suspension is shot
also the city's so crammed I felt like
you know as a taxi would drive through a
street you know obviously people would
clear I felt like these dudes would just
like pull up and a restaurant like all
the patrons would just look back and
like lift up their [ __ ] chairs and
table let the guy through and put it
back down you know like it just felt
that crammed
and you know people don't give a [ __ ]
there people just walk out in front of
your car it doesn't matter but the best
part was this taxi guys he was taking us
back to our hotel he knocked over a
Vespa and just kept going he just looked
he's and he just goes bastardo
reverses resets the car and then just
drives away oh they're usually reversed
over it I think he wanted to like yeah
so he hit the he hit a parked Vespa just
like and then blamed it on the Vespa
yeah that's [ __ ] awesome because it
was parked in a tight corner and he was
just like [ __ ] her and just left came
out of nowhere
that's what he said